zach please sack four and two with a
1.85 era and the sox have not been able
to score against him in two starts so
far this season tim anderson leans it
off right-hander against right-hander
now the one-two swing and a miss got him
with a slider so playsack strikes out
anderson to start tonight's ball game
the socks need dallas kykel to deliver a
strong pitching performance tonight
kykel pitched four scoreless innings
last saturday against the reds in his
return for the injured list he struck
out seven so here is jose ramirez
who is suddenly creeping back into the
mvp conversation as far as the american
league
award is concerned
no score two down the pitch
swung on rip to left down the line it
goes and it'll scoot to the wall and
ramirez has his 12th double
and he is just torturing the white sox
in this series
here's carlos santana
had a bomb last night he's homered twice
in the series he'll bat right-handed
now the 1-0 and a throw back behind the
runner they haven't picked off
sanchez runs him toward third now
montana will run him back towards second
base to throw to anderson they tag him
out inning is over
so grand all with a throw behind
and then a rundown gets ramirez
so now yomer sanchez
getting the start for nick madrigal
today
sanchez in the air right field luplow
back at the wall it is gone bring them
home
yomer sanchez with his first home run of
the season
that gives the white sox a one to
nothing lead here in the third inning he
just proved you don't have to load up or
swing hard it still can travel a long
way and end up in the seats for you
so two on with two outs and cesaro
hernandez to the plate
runners go 3-2 pitch right field down
the line it's a fair ball
kicks off the side wall and they're
going to say it hit the railing was out
of play so the indians will lose a run
on this that's a shame yeah that's too
bad
what a beautiful job by hernan is it
going with that pitch
you got ramirez up there whom uh you
know let's be realistic is it worth
pitching to him right now
i don't think so
[Applause]
and that one on the ground tim anderson
will field it at short slinging across
in time to get ramirez inning over what
do we know
we know that the indians unfortunately
tied the game here in the third inning
on a couple of hits and two men were
left
so one down here in the fourth in this
tie game at one he has money grandal
steps in
and that's strike three but grand all
didn't see he got away from perez so
it'll be an easy toss down to first two
away
five strikeouts three in a row now for
police set
1-1 game here in the fifth nomar mazar
to the plate
that's on the ground hard toward third a
diving stop there at the line by santana
feeds please sack on the back just ahead
of missouri and the innings come to an
end 3-1 on that put out one two three go
the white sox in the fifth one one game
and delano de shields to the plate with
two outs
two-two
swinging and a miss strike three and the
inning is over
a couple of strikeouts here in the frame
for kykel through five it's white sox
one indian one one down top of the order
tim anderson has struck out both times
tonight the pitch swung on bang to third
ramirez goes to second there's one
hernandez got rid of it in a hurry
bounced it santana dug it out ending
ending double play
boy tim anderson's batting title hopes
for the second year in a row
have really taken a hit in this series
reyes you know
over two tonight at ground ball to shore
drowned out to second
kykel sets here's the first one and
that's a high pop-up
on the infield who wants it it's gonna
be over sanchez
he'll make the grab the ending is over
excellent pitching right there from
dallas kykel
and that'll bring up yasmani grand doll
the indians bring the infield in grand
all batting left-handed infield in at
all four positions
yasmani first base side it's off of
santana and moncada comes home sliding
just in case
rondall gets an rbi and the sox take a
2-1 lead
so now it'll be up to mazzara to try to
get at least one maybe both of these
runs home
second and third and mazara ground ball
to the left side it's through for a base
hit here comes abraya to score
right behind him is jimenez he's going
to score
two runs in
on no mar mazzara's
and the white sox have extended their
lead down to four to one and homer
sanchez the batter
he's homer today
cam hills payoff pitch to sanchez
and it swung on hit high in the air to
the left of center to shields back track
at the wall he leaps and he made the
catch
will go to the bottom of the seventh
eloy jimenez coming out of the ball game
i hope he's all right and this is just
for defensive purposes
i think he jammed the front
front foot as he
crossed the plate
and now the bases are loaded with two
down and it's up to cesar hernandez
batting left handed
here it comes
swung on line towards second over the
glove of sanchez into right field a base
hit that'll score a pair as naquin
scores head first slide freeman scores
on his way to third to shields and a
clutch two out two runs single to right
off the bat of cesar hernandez
jose ramirez will swing it from the
right side
and is in the air left center field it
is deep it is off the wall tie game is
to shield scores hernandez around third
racing for home he is safe
jose ramirez does it again a two out two
run double and the indians have scored
four times here in the seventh inning to
take back the lead
santana is over for three and
dallas kykel
should have won his seventh game here
tonight and he'll get a no decision
after a brilliant effort
two-two pitch in here again foul that's
the right side
and over to make the grab and foul
ground is jose abreu over the shoulder
tremendous grab there down that first
base line by jose abreu to end the
inning but damage done four runs come
home
james mccann will pinch it
as the final hope here for the white sox
to keep things going
he fires a swinging a little dribbler
toward first near the bag fairball
santana gloves it steps on the bag ball
game the sweep is complete